senior NBA writer ESPN's the undefeated
is on the phone to break down all things
Kyrie Isiah Thomas and maybe give me
some insight and some hope for my New
York Knicks mark how are you my friend
how many jobs do you have my man I'm
just trying to keep up with you mark
listen I mean you you are honorary
brother man
I'm very brother man now that you have
been told that before but yeah good to
hear from you
mark how are you how are you what's
going on what is your takeaway of the
Isiah Thomas Kyrie Irving trade and and
give me an angle on how I can blame
LeBron because somehow or another
everything has to come back to being
LeBrons fault well I mean I guess you
could blame LeBron that because Kyrie
wanted out because of him so there you
go that's that's easy how do i grade the
trade I'm really impressed by Kobe
Altman I mean you're talking about a GM
that was a month on the job he was
fourth in charge two months ago and all
the odds are against them you walk into
the job and and you're one of your
all-stars and walk out that's the first
thing you got to take care of and the
thing that makes it worse is everybody
knew he wanted out he would impress
impress me about what Kobe did it he got
not in the trade he got an all-star for
an all-star you're not supposed to get
an all-star for an all-star when
everybody knows the Kyrie wants to be
gone Jae Crowder is also a solid
defender gritty guy can hit the three
tough guys he got at LeBron fire I hated
guarding them now he doesn't have to
worry about that anymore there's a guy
that they try and open guard Kevin
Durant in the final some and then also
the thing that nobody is talking about
the most was Toby Albarn was able to get
an unprotected kick from the horrible
Brooklyn net right in the 2018 draft and
as great as this past draft was this
next draft could be even better
they have special big I can't remember a
draft at this many special big but if
they're able to get Michael Porter from
Missouri or Bagley for Duke with the
number one or two pick even if LeBron de
arts it gives them a young superstar to
build with for the future so to me even
as great as getting high there was that
number one pick could be could be Hall
of Fame special so kudos to Kobe Altman
from making the train people are saying
that I mean everybody has an opinion and
and then you know opinions are like
holes in the wall as they say people are
saying that the people are saying that
the Celtics got fleeced why would the
Celtics deplete you know I mean they
gave away a lot of pieces to Cleveland
like I don't understand the rationale of
this trade again I think they're both
great
I think Kyrie just you know head up is
better as far as defensive deficiency
you know he has less of it but why would
Boston give up Jae Crowder you know
because to me he was one of the one of
the people that you helped get you past
Cleveland although they haven't been
able to do it you know and how well will
will Boston be with the addition of
Kyrie Irving and Gordon with the good
hair Hayward well a couple things on
that I read it five years younger than
Isaiah he has like three more years on
this deal so you know what I say I think
they probably would have lost them or
thought they would didn't want to sign
them read long term so now you got a
point guard who's considered you know
with all due respect I was there
probably even better what you're saying
a lot you're adding him and and while
the losing the first-round pick is
curious I think with the addition of
Hayward Jalen Browns gonna be better
Tatum could be the best rookie even
though he'll be coming off the bench
mm-hmm you know Boston now is in a
position to days ago I thought they had
a shot at perhaps getting in the finals
now I think they have a really great
shot at getting to the finals and if
they get banner 18 and you know the next
man I hate to say it I know you hate
them talking about banners up there but
if they get banner 18 then it's going to
be a moot point about the pic they could
care less about the big day they could
care less about losing little Zeke
they'll be they'll be ecstatic and you
know Boston is always about
to win a championship though you know
they're trying to like the Yankees still
swinging to get somebody big and Kyrie
Irving the Me's a really big fish this
is the Rich Eisen show Michael Rapaport
filling in we have mark Spears on the
phone Magic Johnson estate tampering
probe what do you know about this did
this all really stem from him being on
Jimmy Kimmel was that the exchange that
got it into a tampering probe well you
know all live in the same area well you
know the LA got it there's got to be
ways that they cross paths and you know
the thing with magic now you got to
ensure that he knows all the rules he he
might have been an executive before but
he wasn't this close to everything
before so that that's going to be tough
if they lose it that the Lakers lose
this this is horrible absolutely
horrible because you know I actually
thought they should have traded for Paul
George already knowing that he wanted to
go there and they gambled by waiting to
see what happened you know who knows he
might like it in OKC but if they can't
get far because of this you know that
also could have an after effect on
LeBron James possibility of him going
there as well but but at this but did
this whole tampering thing come up
actually from that comment that he made
on the Jimmy Kimmel show or is there
something deeper to it that that I
missed out on even though I am very well
in the know cuz to me what he did on
Jimmy Kimmel he's just talking and you
know it was like he said if and it was
you know it was a hypothetical thing I
don't understand that's just something
else it's gotta be something else
because that's something that's happened
months ago you know it wouldn't have
been that big a deal now if that was it
it has got to be more than that so that
I mean you hear guys say stuff on TV
shows all the time I I'd be shocked at
that if that's if that's what the big
deal is then the Lakers have nothing to
worry about but it's got to be something
more Michael Rapaport here with Mark
Spears on the Rich Eisen show but we
have a poll today Brockman let's share
with
with mark and see what he thinks about
this yeah Margo who do you want to see
in the 2018 NBA Finals Warriors Cavs for
warriors Celtics through the Rockets in
their rockets Cavs Rockets Celtics or
none of the above I wouldn't mind seeing
warriors something I mean I covered the
Celtics for a while I liked the food
there you know I haven't been illegal in
a while they got a place called new
jumbo seafood Michael you gotta go it's
open at 2:00 a.m. they have this big
tank with fish in it and you go there
and you pick what fish you want and you
see the fish get murder ha ha ha and
then so so I I root for places you know
so if it's Golden State then I don't
have to go anywhere you know and then I
can fly to Boston and I'm one of the
brothers that actually likes Boston so
yeah let's go with that all right is it
a foregone conclusion mark though that
Golden State's gonna make it back to the
finals the way they they actually got
better if we can believe that they got
better this offseason
people are sleeping on the cast be
signing I think he was a great addition
he runs the floor he had sides he could
hit 3 you could block shot he's a nice
addition for the ward swaggy G I talked
to him during the ESPYs
he's super excited he'll fall in line
and be a better player than he's ever
been
you know JaVale McGee is back Patrick
McCleary will be better you know
obviously Iguodala and live a
centre-back keep an eye on a young kid
damon jones who was a d-league Rookie of
the Month the last month of the d-league
loaded the better kevin durant will be
more comfortable barring injury this is
a force that probably won't be stopped
for a couple years
Marc the Philadelphia 76ers they trusted
the process and now it's time to
actually make it happen will the
Philadelphia 76ers be in the playoffs in
this upcoming season barring injury and
that's a you know with with this team of
Joel and b-sides
sighs in history will the Phillip
Philadelphia Sixers process actually
come to fruition
you know what let's just assume that
they're healthy okay assuming that they
are healthy I still think if they make
it they'll be like late like an eight or
seven and eight and the reason why I say
that if there's just too much
inexperience there a JJ reddick helps as
far as the veteran presidents but you
know you got too many guys that are
trying to figure out hmm
Simmons folks never played an NBA games
before these are major parts of their
team you know and then MB don't played
in a handful of games although he's been
spectacular in the games that he's
played Sarris it's just so much you that
you can that you have to depend on
Michael let's go back to the early 2000s
remember that Clippers team but Quentin
Richardson Lamar oh oh hmm you're in
Andheri
it's miles Elton Brand and Andre Miller
Mia that they're gonna be fun hmm
they're gonna be young but I do think
the growing pains this next season and
the egos that are there probably will be
too much to overcome a lot I don't think
they'll make it this year I see them
being a year away it's been a crazy
dramatic sometimes it's felt like the
days of our lives
NBA offseason will there be any big
moves before training camp or or can I
can I forget about the this a ballerina
offseason Oh Marc fine give it to me on
the Knicks you want to make me nuts oh
you can't see me but the people at home
could see me I'm wearing a suit and a
tie today
by the end of this segment don't be
surprised if it comes off we got two
minutes give me something I could look
forward to with the next mark I don't
know man I'm trying I'm trying
look Scott Perry is a great general
manager
good will he's a great general manager
will he be actually general managing and
what does Steve Mills do here's a good
question for you you're an NBA insider
you're a senior your senior NBA writer
for ESPN's on
feed it what does Steve Mills do tell me
what his job is and what is his skill
set and what is his strength that he
brings to the Days Inn for 56 years the
thing is we won't take more of the
president role where there's when you're
the president you got your hands
involved in everything but believe me
when I tell you this Scott Perry will
make a strong imprint they're not going
to do a stupid trade everything
everything's going to be well thought
out he will make a good move from now or
the best movie can make under the
situation so if he hasn't done it yet
it's because the right moves not there
be patient
bring me back when it's done but I'm
confident that Scott Perry make a great
move from level do you think Carmelo
Anthony will select the season as a New
York Knick know what with you had if you
had to you know bet the house the same
house that you're gonna win if you bet
on Floyd Mayweather Saturday night
you're betting the house who would you
say Carmelo is what team is he gonna go
to you know what I don't I can't say
what team he should go to but here's the
thing if if I'm New York if I'm Toronto
or I'm Washington I'm trying to get them
because you're behind now if you're them
you're not Cleveland you're not you're
not Boston you're a big step behind
how can you catch up in that arms race
you know try to get melot melot I'm sure
would love playing back home in the
Baltimore area with the Wizards I think
mister I would love to have him in
Toronto but I don't know that New York
would make a deal with him but if I'm
those teams I'm trying to get Melo
that being said melon wants to go to
Houston so Houston has to give up Eric
Gordon
you can't Euston is being greedy they're
being bluntness you can't you got to
give up something to get something if
they really want Melo that badly they're
gonna have to give up Eric Gordon to do
it and so let's see who blinks there all
right well Marc Spears senior MBA writer
for ESPN's undefeated I appreciate the
insight
I appreciate the New York Knicks
optimism okay real quick what do you got
for me
who wins the big three championships oh
man that's a good question the big three
championship you know I am a
sideline reporter so I have to be
impartial but it is Vegas if I have if I
if I was betting and I and I and I cared
money or if I was betting and and I
would say that trilogy is undefeated
Kenya Martin's team led by Rick Mahorn
that's who I would say our star Lou
okay well Rashard Lewis okay Kenya is
gonna be mad at me for saying that
but I think we're Shar Lewis has a big
day and if I'm an NBA team I give us our
chance Oh easy and I can tell you one
thing the big three finals Saturday will
be more physical than the fight Saturday
night Marc Spears thank you for joining
Rich Eisen show I appreciate her brother
thank you so much the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country
and audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy